okay let's compare Cloud functions and
Cloud run both our serverless compute
products that can scale from zero to
Lots Cloud functions works well for
workloads focused on connecting your
platform while Cloud run is best for
well running Services Cloud functions
fully manages the configuration so you
just bring the code while Cloud run
offers the flexibility you need for
running Services giving you control of
things like your web server or language
runtime and manages the rest
but you don't have to pick just one get
your project started fast deploying your
code to Cloud functions and then evolve
it into a more complex service later if
you need by easily migrating it to Cloud
run a complete rundown is penned in the
comments